this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
today's episode he's going to be taking
a look at more of the weapons from
battlefield 2042 we can't of course have
a near future set game without some
completely new guns and this is one of
those so it's a bit of a head scratcher
but it looks suitably futuristic and it
seems to set itself apart from the other
weapons in the game pretty well for more
make sure to check out our previous
episode on battlefield 2042 and if there
are any other games guns and mechanics
that you guys want to see jonathan break
down let us know in the comment section
below and of course if you'd like to
help out the royal armies museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
what would be
potentially a bit of a bit of an older
design by the time frame of this game
the fn scar we have an example here so
the one we've got here is the scar l for
light just found a bit less favor than
the scar h the heavy which is in 7 16
nato the proportions to me a little hard
to see without a profile view they look
a little bit more like the 556 gun this
one there's a fair it's obviously has a
longer receiver a longer ejection
opening but it's the same
design might be somewhat controllable
and controllable in automatic fire just
because you're losing some of that
pressure the pressure drops off as the
as the bullet leaves the short barrel
which limits your reduces your your
ballistic effectiveness but would has
also in theory reduce the recoil
somewhat although it would still be a
real handful because it's such a short
weapon it has an automatic function
you wouldn't recommend using it i don't
know how well it handles in the game
so the battlefield tradition of
inserting some unexpected guns continues
with um something that's called the
v-car car for carbine though i imagine
which is actually a kel-tec design now
kel-tec are a fascinating american
company that come up with all sorts of
weird and wacky designs and this is a
carbine spin-off of their pmr-30 pistol
and so
we're expected to believe that this is
this has been adopted from military
service which seems unlikely especially
in the
cmr-30s caliber which is uh tutu
winchester magnum now that's quite a
high velocity cartridge for a pistol
cartridge but it is still a pistol class
cartridge so it's perhaps questionable
in terms of lethality then again in the
game it's clearly meant to serve as a
sort of lesser weapon anyway i suppose
in the context of the game we have these
sort of semi-mercenary characters so the
fact that this is not a military firearm
per se
isn't really a showstopper for this game
this is the uh carving i think it is um
it's really a designated martian rifle
dmr which is mostly how we see it used
there although oddly it has the same
smart rail system as all of the other
guns in the game so i'm somehow all of
the nations of the world standardize on
this future rail system it's not too
outlandish we've all managed to
standardize on picatinny rails can't
really speak to the effectiveness or the
realism of this i've only seen pictures
like most of us
various export bands and sanctions and
things mean that we don't get our hands
on the very latest russian firearms
worth mentioning this is a kalashnikov i
mean it's not it's not an ak
but it's a pr it is a product of
kalashnikov concern uh one of a number
that they they've been working on to
sort of well diversify and future-proof
the business because they can't rely on
the good old ak forever so a nice
futuristic looking real world gun pretty
well represented it's got you know
it's semi-automatic it's powerful
i think they've done a good job on it
[Applause]
well i like what i'm seeing of the saiga
12 in this it's got some good punchy
rate of fire and sound effect and
effectiveness as well what seems like a
a reasonable range for shotgun for
buckshot people are getting taken out in
fairly short order so we do have a um
a couple of saga as well actually this
it's
quite vanilla though compared to the one
in the game owls has got a short barrel
and a breaching attachment on it makes
it look quite purposeful i think it's
the word but it's otherwise pretty
standard the one in the game is i
believe based on a a more modern variant
anyway and it's looks quite well a
little bit three-gun so a little bit
competition it's got the rail system on
it it's got a side charging handle with
the big open slot in the side probably
not ideal for for military purposes it's
got a receiver that takes a ar-15 pistol
grip so you can swap that out for
different things and the buffer tube on
the back for i'm not i can't recall if
the if they're compatible with actual
ar-15 butt stocks but it's it's of that
style it's got cheek riser on it so uh
tricked out but not
too tricked out doesn't even have an
optical sight on it in this
configuration that dave put together but
he has put a little charm on there just
to uh just to remind me
right this is um this is a gun that
actually exists both as the pkp passion
egg which is a sort of lmg specific
variant of the pkm and then this fairly
wacky looking bullpup version of the pkp
that also does exist it's not a factory
produced
gun i believe it was invented by all
four a certain special forces unit that
wanted an even more compact assault
machine gun and it achieves that of
course so it's not it's not a future
weapon really it's something that's in
use now it might still be in use then
maybe a trend starts for doing this
maybe maybe the pkp supplants the pkm
around the world and so bullpup versions
of it become more prominent it's um not
unreasonable to have it in the game um
it's nice to see incidentally that the
muzzle flashes aren't crazy in this game
they're quite plausibly sized and and
rendered we've moved away finally from
the gigantic multi-star flashes on
absolutely everything that actually made
it harder to shoot in the game never
mind if you're shooting the thing in
real life things are looking a little
bit more plausible now i think
this is the what used to be the
tmp and is now the bnt mp9 with a few
tactical bells and whistles i think that
might just be the latest version of the
mp9 actually but what i what keeps
distracting me is the charm hanging off
the side which
which i couldn't spot what it was at
first but it is in fact a glow stick so
this is a machine pistol for a 90s raver
i suppose might draw unwanted fire in
your direction if you have a glowing
item hanging off the side of your gun
and pretty distracting as well while
you're shooting
so sometimes games teach me about guns i
say sometimes all the time when i was
younger one of my main
main ways of learning about firearms
until you realize there's a whole wealth
of books and uh
trusted sources and contacts out there
but um occasionally something crops up
that i've not heard of
and what is actually a dsr precision
rifle it's a modern cnc machine desert
tan tactical looking sniper rifle with
some charms hanging off it but what's
interesting about it i think or visually
interesting about it and also in terms
of gameplay changes
is the fact that from first person view
you would be forgiven for thinking this
was a conventional rifle with a magazine
and a magazine well in front of your
pistol grip in front of your trigger
but then you realize actually no this is
a bullpup with the action and magazine
at the back and what's in the faux
magazine well in front is a spare
magazine so this is not unheard of this
is the inverse of the case with the
stayer scout rifle where it's a
conventional but short precision rifle
as well actually and there's a magazine
back here in buttstock that looks like
it could be a ballpark configuration but
it's not it's a spare magazine so the
opposite of this it's unusual in that
respect which is always good new stuff
is is always good whether it's
meaningfully any different than an
equivalent bolt action sniper from
another game i don't know we'll have to
see how the gameplay shakes out
an interesting trend to follow in the
modern firearms is actually a really old
trend modular systems where you have
like a fire control unit with a trigger
and you have like a
the slide in the barrel we've taken this
idea of a stock to the next level what
twice actually firstly mounting the
whole gun into a stock like into a
chassis like the caa roni we've now gone
to the next level
with this thing where it's a sig p320
but you get rid of the frame and you
replace that with a carbine frame if
that makes sense so you drop in your
sliding barrel you drop in your fire
control unit and you have a little
pistol carbine so we get features like a
little flick out stock we see the the
player hit the button and the stock
flicks out for quick deployment so you
can shoot this thing one or two handed
as a pistol or you can deploy the stock
and shoulder it for much increased
accuracy it gives it gives options now
this is something that's probably of
more use to
police security forces something like
that where they have a
limited number of pistols in the
inventory and
maybe you don't want a 556 carbine for a
particular application so you convert
like a transformer your pistol
into a carbine at least that's kind of
what the intent is remains to be seen
whether this will really catch on but
you know in this freedom of choice
environment where we have essentially
mercenaries running around with kit that
they've acquired you might well want a
very bulky pistol that allows you
especially if you're using a sniper or
dmr as your primary something that can
function as a pistol caliber carbine
we can't of course have a near future
set game without some completely new
guns and this is one of those so ac42
i'm not sure what significance that may
or may not have this thing looks more
than anything
like the thales f90 which is the um
steyr aug modernized with a chunkier
modern receiver with modular features
it's got some of the same design cues on
there certainly as that it's got a lot
of recoil and i think that's because i'm
seeing it mostly in burst mode so we've
got a very high rate of fire pretty much
hyper burst i would say but the weird
thing about the recoil is i've seen this
in games before rather than going up and
right it kind of goes up and left which
doesn't really make much sense in terms
of how a rifle
interfaces with your upper body so it's
a bit of a head scratcher but it looks
suitably futuristic and it seems to set
itself apart from the other weapons in
the game
pretty well
pp19 bison
i think is the right pronunciation sorry
this is a bit clattery now this is a
perhaps an odd choice because as far as
i know this
fairly famous but slightly clunky
helical magazine
feed arrangement on the pp19 has been
superseded by a fairly mp5s
box magazine
magazine well so same basic design but
with a conventional magazine feed so
perhaps this is still being being made
and improved upon i don't know but as
far as i knew this thing was kind of
fading away so whether this would still
be around in the future i don't know
well it'd still be around it'd still be
some in existence but whether they would
receive the smart rail upgrade that we
see on this one is perhaps questionable
now probably more interesting for me
than
than this gun
is the optical sight which has got two
well i know some interesting nods toward
current and near future tech we've got a
battery indicator we've got a wi-fi and
some sort of mobile signal
indicator which is interesting so it's
networked in some way although what
features that provides you is not clear
from from gameplay the two useful
features for gameplay though are a a
rangefinder bottom left this is this is
becoming very common in sights nowadays
and then bottom right we have a much
more useful iteration of the good old
pulse rifle ammo counter from aliens
where instead of having to
check the side of your gun
it's actually in your field of view in
your sight i don't see any harm in
having that in there and i i'm sure that
someone at some point will have an
integrated round counter in
your site
okay this is an interesting choice
this is
actually the denelle ntw 20 or it's
that's the real world gun which is a 20
millimeter but a shortened 20 millimeter
it's not like the spanner around it's
truncated to make it possible to fire it
from the shoulder now this version is
called the ntw 50 implying that maybe
it's 50 bmg but the effect that we see
it having here on some pretty serious um
armored vehicles it's got to be some
sort of armor-piercing 20 millimeter
round
minimum really so the fact the fact that
you have a rifle that's capable of doing
damage to vehicles in-game it's actually
having an effect is a good thing because
there's been a you know often your
barrets and things are they just end up
being used as glorified sniper rifles
and they do very little against vehicles
in this you really get a sense of the
power of this thing which is offset by
it being quite slow to wheel it's got a
low magazine capacity and of course the
scope limits your field of view to try
and use it in close quarters
and it was all going so well
this kind of breaks uh immersion for me
i must admit this is a marlin model 1895
with m lock rail system
and inexplicably
the trademark battlefield 2042 smart
powered rail is on there as well at
least it's a moderately powerful
cartridge 4570 it's got a fair bit of
oops behind it but it's not going to
penetrate
contemporary body armor which should
still be in use at this time if not more
more prolific than it is now it would
hurt but it's not going to penetrate
much at all frankly about the only
advantage it has is the ability to keep
it topped up with rounds which in
certain close quarters situations might
be an advantage but not really when you
see when you see the the drills people
can do in terms of reloading now stuff
like this to me would make more sense in
its like old west trim
as something that's just a found object
in the level to use for fun or for
bragging rights to say you killed
someone with it the idea that this is
somehow a contemporary weapon in the
future is just nonsense
we've always got links in the
description for you to follow if you
wish to go over to the royal armory site
where we have the ability for you to
donate if you would wish to
perhaps become a member and we have our
events our social media channels our own
youtube channel as well and something i
thought i'd mention some of you might be
interested i'm also associate editor of
the journal rmax which is an academic
journal that's not not perhaps for
everyone's uh taste
but it does cover um
firearms from about 1880 to the present
day
in a serious way so if you really want
to deep dive into some some interesting
topics around
historic firearms but all the way up to
the present day it might be worth
checking out over on uh there's a link
in the description for that as well
but i'll see you again next time thanks
very much
[Music]
you